hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast gene expression analysis
critical factors for overcoming
challenges using qpcr it is presented by
marina SRAM PhD global product manager
for kaijin and ena Shore fluke PhD
director of global marketing for life
science at kyochon I am Judy O'Rourke of
lab routes and I'll be your moderator
for today's event we are delighted to
bring you this educational web seminar
presented by lab roots and sponsored by
kaya gen for more information about our
sponsor visit w-w-w you can calm the
savannahs interactive we encourage you
to participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at anytime you
want during the presentation just click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen and type your
questions into the drop-down box that
appears on the screen well answer as
many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation if you have
trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please click on the help
desk button located in the promotional
board at the bottom center of your
screen or use the ask a question box to
let us know you're having a problem this
presentation is educational and thus
offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credit tab located in the top right
corner of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits please join me in welcoming dr.
SRAM and dr. Shara fluke I will now turn
the presentation over to them
you
yeah I know everyone and thank you for
the kind introduction Judy thank you all
for joining this webinar around qPCR and
really what the critical factors for
overcoming the challenges associated
with qPCR are as really every step for a
qPCR experiment methods from the sample
to the actual final result at the end we
will guide you through the different
steps of a gene expression analysis
experiment using qPCR as an SI method at
the end we have divided this webinar
into two parts and in the first part I
will guide you through the steps from
the sample to the isolation so that you
have RNA to be then ready to move into
your qpcr experiment the second part
will be covered by my colleague inertia
of group cotton product shown here are
intended for molecular biology
applications these products are not
intended for the diagnosis prevention or
treatment of disease this is the agenda
of our webinar today and as mentioned
our first guide you through an
introduction of gene expression and then
really what the steps of the workflow
are and what matters and at the end the
challenges associated with these
different steps concerning the sample
preparation mainly and the current
solutions we have and finish with a
summary before handing over to you now
so when we talk about gene expression
analysis we actually need to start with
the central dogma of molecular biology
that we all learned in high school or
latest during our biology studies and
within the cell information always flows
from DNA to RNA and then all the way to
the protein so DNA gets transcribed into
RNA before it's translated into the
protein and if we then look at the
complete RNA analysis we are talking
about the transcriptome analysis that is
usually mrna so coding RNA analysis
however if we expand the view away from
the classical mRNA analysis and the
central dogma we
analysis of RNA can actually be very
complex and so is gene expression with
different ways of regulation within the
cell different types of RNAs actually
non-coding RNAs that are regulating RNA
expression and also different pathways
of transport of RNA within the cell out
of the out of the cell nucleus into the
cytoplasm and all of this gene
expression can become very complex if
you start to look into the details and
out of the classical mRNA gene
expression analysis we also like to talk
about a complete universe of different
RNA species there are so many different
types listed here on this slide of RNA
besides the classical messenger mRNA
there's also ribosomal RNA transfer RNA
and other regulatory RNAs like micro
rnas or long non-coding rnas
all of these different RNA species are
extensively studied and if you want to
get an overview of these different RNA
species you can actually request the RNA
universe poster depicted on this image
here on the left side also as an
overview for your lab why do people
analyze gene expression always always
already giving you some hints in the
short introduction so the main reason is
that just by looking into DNA people are
not able to really answer all the
questions around the complexity of cells
and their different functions so
cellular function really differs based
on the spectra of genes that are
expressed as well as the level of
expression and then you could also add
the level of regulation to this through
micro RNAs or other regulatory RNAs so
gene expression is studied in a lot of
different contexts and I'm just listing
from here but there are many more to add
to that some of them are for instance
gene function so understanding the rule
of genes for instance at a certain
developmental phase another very obvious
area is disease research where people
look into
Renea or micro RNA expression to
identify biomarkers and I said there are
many more so the question for gene
expression analysis is always when where
and how strong are genes expressed
moving on to the different steps of a
gene expression workflow you always need
to come somehow from your sample
whatever that is to the actual inside
here at the end through an analysis step
and then a data analysis and
interpretation step each of these steps
is extremely important and should be
taken with certain care and also
requires dedicated solutions to give you
the best result at the end and
especially for RNA this is crucial
because RNA is about accurately
quantifying the amount of RNA that's
present it's not a yes/no decision as
for example you have it for DNA
mutations RNA expression profiles change
at the moment the sample is collected so
prevention of RNA degradation is
actually key and sample collection and
stabilization methods need to be handled
very carefully and then also RNA
purification is actually not that
trivial because you need to lice your
sample you need to efficiently release
the RNA and then also get rid of
proteins and other contaminants so
purification efficiency is extremely
important and after the RNA is isolated
you should always do QC a thorough QC on
your RNA sample before proceeding to
downstream essays the other steps of the
workflow here will be covered in more
detail in the second part with my
colleague ena so what are the different
challenges associated with these steps
let's first look into the sample
collection and sterilization and I was
already mentioning that changes in mRNA
levels of following the sample
harvesting so that's stabilization of
your sample for RNA analysis is
extremely important I'm actually quoting
a paper here on the left side which
that around 60 to 70% of all problems
occurring in laboratory Diagnostics can
be associated with pre-analytical errors
and wrong mishandling of the sample and
problems during the collection and
preparation of drawing of the specimen
so handling your sample very carefully
and stabilizing it is extremely
important so that you are preventing as
a method the rotation of your mRNA or
also induction of genes at the time
point of connection an example for a
stabilization reagent is RNA data which
you can use for tissue samples and here
we are showing an experiment where we
are comparing an unstabilized sample and
in this case the expression of the
housekeeping gene gap the age versus the
expression profile of that same gene in
an RNA liter stabilized sample and you
can see that on the left side in the
unstabilized case only after a couple of
minutes
the RNA degradation already kicks in and
you can see on this gel a very
significant degradation of RNA again
highlighting the importance of purpose
stabilization and then also in general
some samples can be quite challenging
and it's actually more than you would
think in first place the reason is that
also the downstream assays for instance
can be very sensitive and they can be
very sensitive in particular to
impurities or contaminations like
proteins very often and thematic
reactions in the downstream assays can
be inhibited through these impurities
and you would see that in the
performance of your downstream si which
might lead to wrong quantification of
your RNA and then also isolating intact
total RNA is very important for some
applications like for example fusion
gene detection and here some tissues can
be very problematic especially sspe
tissues
the FFPE treatment itself is very harsh
and can lead to degradation of the RNA
there's also a trend towards systems
biology where people like to isolate
different types of fire molecules for
example micro RNA and RNA to really
understand what also happening at the
level of RNA regulation and then
quantitation is extremely important for
for real-time PCR but also for other
downstream assays it's really accurately
quantify the sample is key for a
comparable for comparable results and
also requires comparable sample quality
and sort of a standardized RNA isolation
method
so if you ever wondered why we have so
many different RNA purification kits
it's actually because we realize that a
1/5 all solution certainly not working
for so many different sample types so
it's important to have dedicated
solutions with dedicated protocols and
ingredients for very specific sand
supplies
there are other critical factors for RNA
purification mainly around the quality
of the purified RNA usually people look
into three different parameters for RNA
QC which are integrity purity and then
also RNA yield so the quality of the
starting sample material is really key
for the integrity and also the purity
however there are methods for example a
phenol treatment or dedicated person
solution to really optimize the RNA
purity even from very challenging or
five-hour protein rich samples
inactivation of RNAs is also very
important because rnases are becoming
active as soon as the RNA is isolated so
these need to be very efficiently
inactivated you might also call purify
inhibitors which might then later on
inhibit the RT step so getting rid of
these inhibitors removing them from the
RNA LD that is also very important you
might also have protein contamination
but there are ways to to remove that
efficiency and I'll tell you a little
bit about that in the coming slide
another important fact especially in the
area of NGS where you can look in an
unbiased way into your sample but also
for very sensitive rt-pcr SAS like
antonova j DNA contamination is also
another important issue to consider for
getting rid of your G DNA is it might
interfere with your downstream si is
also very important
I was already mentioning that cell and
tissue lysis is another key for getting
as much as possible out of your samples
or getting very high RNA yield and I
want to remind you at this point that
the content of the mRNA content of total
RNA in your cell is only around one to
five percent so if you are looking into
gene expression profiling using mRNA
you're really after only one to five
percent of your total RNA that also why
our our Anita kids are optimized to
isolate RNA larger than 200 base pairs
to sort of enrich for the small portion
of mRNA within the total RNA content so
if you're looking for a solution to get
the small and the large RNAs we usually
recommend the music product line for RNA
for mrna studies our an easy products
would be the best solution for you
so one special let's say more tricky
sample type are actually fibers tissue
samples like heart muscle and other
collagen or contractile protein enriched
tissue types so these kind of proteins
can interfere with the isolation process
so removing these is very key and there
are two ways how you could remove these
either through a proteinase k digest but
another alternative is through a phenyl
chloroform treatment upfront before
you're actually going on the column if
you're using spin columns in your
protocol it's very important to remove
such large proteins before you're going
on to the spin column because they could
actually sort of interfere with a
membrane and avoid optimal RNA isolation
through clogging of the membrane if you
are working with a phenyl chloroform
upfront treatment it's very efficient to
our remove contaminants like protein
complexes but also to get rid of DNA
however it's important that you are very
care
we pipetting the aqueous phase out and
avoid phenyl carryover that is important
because phenol is sort of mimicking a
higher RNA yield in your RNA QC and this
is shown here in the graph at the bottom
where a sample with RNA where a sample
RNA con where an RNA sample contaminated
with phenol is actually showing you a
higher RNA yield compared to the pure
RNA sample so be aware that phenol is
absorbing in the same wavelength range
as RNA is removal of genomic DNA is
another important point that I already
mentioned and that is important because
trace amount of genomic DNA in your
sample can actually compromise the
accuracy of sensitive applications like
real-time PCR would also like NGS so
avoiding gDNA carry over into your essay
is extremely important and there are
several ways how you can tackle this the
classical way is through a dnase
digestion however that is adding another
15 minute step to your workflow and
alternatives are our G DNA Eliminator
columns contained in the other music
basket or the G DNA eliminated solution
in the RNA DeCoste universal kit so
these are non enzymatic ways to remove
the DNA another way to remove the DNA is
also through very clever primer design
but that can be quite tricky to
accomplish but also through using for
example a rt-pcr chemistry that contains
gDNA removal for example our quanta new
where kids are containing AG DNA why
bother to get rid of G DNA of remaining
in your sample
so let me summarize this part of the
presentation before handing over to ena
what is important to consider for RNA
stabilization and sample prep when
you're looking into gene expression
analysis
first of all cells contain different
types of RNA species with a variety of
different functions analysis of full RNA
content provides a full picture of
transcriptional landscape however it's
also important that you know exactly
what you want to do in your experiment
and then decide on the best isolation
chemistry for example if you're just
looking into mRNA then you might not
need a chemistry that's isolated total
RNA but for example or anything might be
an option for you
stabilization of RNA and the RNA
profiles is very important to preserve
gene expression status during sample
collection transfers and storage and we
have a complete dedicated product line
for that also for human samples we have
the fact gene products available so that
can give you more look for this product
name if you if you look for more
information on that we also have a lot
of dedicated RNA sample prep kits
available and these are really needed to
obtain optimal RNA years with good
quantity from literally any downstream
sample and with that I'm at the end of
my presentation before we are moving to
the questions I would actually like to
hand over to my colleague ena for the
second part of this presentation thank
you
thank you very much marina and Toodee
for this nice introduction and welcome
to everybody
you
you
I would like now to go over to more the
gene expression analyzers part in the
second part of the webinar today I will
cover and discuss some critical steps
can see that here some critical steps
for real-time PCR and alliances but also
some improved methods for C DNA
synthesis then we come to real-time PCR
essentials and then some new solutions
is Ravina already mentioned according
real-time pcr from our R&D department
starting with the critical steps for
real-time PCR analyzes in this slide
that verinha already shows I think it's
important to stress that once again
because when addressing real-time PCR
variability it is important to talk
about these critical steps that are
influencing the RNA quality the first
important step is of course the
prevention of the RNA degradation and
the efficient purification of the RNA I
just want to highlight this important
step again which was already presented
by my colleague Verena because it's
important to understand here that the
irony quality is only that good s
destabilization and purification methods
used important is here to preserve the
real irony profile after ex vivo the
cDNA step is then the one that is really
major important people because here
where the major source for variability
once again the arti efficiency depends
on the initial RNA quality and quantity
but also on the individuals carried over
from the unit as a purification step
different ID RTI enzymes and priming
methods will yield in different results
and very often we also have the
discussion if we should use one step
versus two step real-time PCR results
which have different advantages and
disadvantages when it comes to the
real-time PCR a PCR experiment here the
result is affected by the specificity of
the primers and the probes when you work
with probe based real-time PCR but
especially with cyber green it is very
important to check the experimental
setup and using internal process
controls as well as external controls to
do either absolute or relative
quantification measured
you
in the next part I would like to focus
more on the improved methods of C DNA
synthesis on the RT step
we will have a look at the RT step s is
a source of the most variability in
real-time PCR experiment and I would
like to stress that once again I've
listed here the most important critical
sectors that could influence the RT step
important here is of course the quality
of the Erinyes starting material which
is influencing the air RT enzyme
efficiency so phenol alcohol or salt
contaminations or other protein based
inhibitors carried over from the RNA
isolation step can affect the RT enzyme
efficiency important and we will look
into that is also the affinity of the
R&A RT enzyme towards the arrow name
which is critical if we would like to
avoid secondary structural effects the
choice of priming strategy rather than
priming or ology code et is critical
step we'll cover that in a minute
genomic DNA elimination should be
eliminated for successful result next
point we will address sequences near the
5 prime end affect the cDNA yield and
it's a critical point depending on the
experiment you're planning of course and
one part will also be what internal
controls should be used at the end and I
would like to give a little bit of
guidance here so what have we done in
our R&D department so what is you
because of all the points I try to
stress out we have developed in our R&D
department in the URT called quanta nova
reverse transcriptase and i would like
to explain why we think that we achieve
with that new RTI enzyme high efficiency
and sensitivity according real-time PCR
experiments
this quant ANOVA RT leads to high
efficiency transcription for sensitive
detection even for low abundant targets
- and it's a novel blend of a hot start
RT that can be used for a wide range of
RNA amount from 10 picogram to 5 micro
gram it has a very unique high affinity
to Aaron a which leads the highest
sensitivity and even with you can use it
with difficult templates and also for
all starting material even if you have a
high sugar or glucose it content or when
working with the LPS contaminations in
there that is not a problem at all we
have also included that is often you and
Aaron ace inhibitor and you will see in
a minute
the protocol is including already a G
DNA removal buffer which is integrated
in the protocol which makes it very easy
to use and we are using an optimized or
liquidity and random primer mix and with
what is very very unique is now we have
included an internal control to monitor
the cDNA synthesis efficiency but you
can of course use it optionally and
spike it in or you can leave it out it's
up to your experimental setup
on the next line of access the easy
protocol because of course when working
with RNA it's very important that we are
working fast because RNA dick degrades
also very easily the we have developed a
very fast see DNA synthesis procedure
which takes only 20 minutes is it it's
three steps so you use the RNA remove
the genomic DNA which is incubation two
minutes at 42 degrees here you can then
optionally spike in the internal control
RNA which monitors then are the success
of your real-time that you're seeding a
synthesis but I will come to that in a
minute the next step is you synthesize
the cDNA 15 minutes at 42 degrees and
just stop the reactor which is at 95
degrees for three minutes and you get
cDNA without a cDNA contamination into
twenty minutes
if you were to the internal control
because that is very unique we are using
here a synthetic RNA that can be
optimally used in your experiment and
you monitor is the reverse transcription
step went successfully the internal
control is intended to report instrument
or chemistry failures or errors in the
SA setup or the presence of inhibitors
inhibitors as Verena already mentioned
could be phenol ethanol SDS EDTA that
may remain from the lysis and
purification step of your RNA isolation
procedure
the internal control is so new and I
would like to show you what we have done
or what four experiments we have done in
the laboratory because the quantity Nova
internal control indicates the
inhibition of failure of the RTO qpcr
reaction by city shift behavior similar
as many tested transcripts in this
experiment that you can see on that
slide we spike different amounts of SDS
which is an inhibitor into the qPCR
reactor and you can see on those
experiments on both experiments that the
the indicated inhibition you can see in
the delay of the CT values and this
gives you therefore a clear guidance of
the quality of the input material you
have
the internal control that we have used
is not the same as the endogenous
reference control or team we come to
this external our control in a minute
what I also would like to show you
because that is also new is the D DNA
removal it's an offense efficient
removal of contaminating genomic DNA
which ensures precise quantification of
the transcripts on this slide you can
see at the real-time PCR analysis of a
CTB with and without using the G DNA
removal step the dynamic DNA purified is
purified from human whole blood and
different amount of T DNA were spiked
into the C DNA synthesis fraction
prepared using the quant ANOVA our
ticket without dynamic our DNA removal
you can see that the third genomic DNA
contamination resulted in a very strong
signal and this signal was successfully
eliminated by the integrated genomic DNA
removal step that is integrated in the
continuity systems
because I'm very often asked also
according the choice of the primers for
liquidity or so we use random priming or
a liquidity and venom priming so we have
tested that of course in our laboratory
we have used the 10 KB transcript with
an m3 cone which is 2 KB and another one
which is six KP you away from the three
prime and on the left hand side you can
see the results of the antique on which
is 2 KB away from the 3 prime end and
here are you can clearly see that random
priming is not maybe not the best choice
or Liggett DT would be the best one here
and therefore we are going for oligo DT
and random priming when the amplicon is
6 kb away from the 3 prime and you can
see the situation has changed completely
because here or liquidity will not give
the most efficient results but random
priming is here the best solution but
also a liquidity and random priming
gives very similar results that's why we
are using from the client side or
liquidity and random priming to give you
the best result no matter how far away
your trend amplicon is away from 3 prime
end for example
as a summary arm I hope I could show you
that we have developed something new in
our hydrogen R&D department another
quanta Nova art eclipse which is high
sensitive to your novel enzyme that we
are using we can synthesize cDNA remove
genomic DNA in just 20 minutes the
genomic DNA removal step is integrated
you do not even have to think about that
our reverse transcription from all
regions is possible because we do these
random priming and auditable DT priming
principle and you can use an internal or
spike in control if you would like to
have a process control in your
experiment
now coming to some real Campisi are
essentials i would like to start here
with some basic are pcr kinetics us to
put everybody on the same page what you
can see here is the pcr rechtin can of
course be divided in three phases
that's the exponential phase the linear
phase and the plateau phase important is
the linear phase of course where the
generation of the PCR product is
directly proportional to the input
target molecule per PCR cycle the
plateau phase of course should not be
used to measure the CT values as here we
can see different effects because the
half-life of the PCR enzyme is going
down it's inhibited by the end product
and we are running out of the PCR
substrate of course
so on the next slide I tried to get a
little bit more into detail according
the CT vessel cycle so what is that this
defines the cycle number at which the
first and signal reaches the detection
threshold that is very much also
dependent on your real-time cycle
because it's the time point when the
first and signal can be detected by your
real-time PCR cycle
I'm very often asked of the card in
quantification methods in real time PCR
and here we have two very important real
quantification methods for real time PCR
is absolute and relative quantification
for relative quantification we measure
the target mRNA copies relative to an
external Erin a standard and per cell in
the unit mass and that is for example
using a pH or error RNA as a internal
Erin a control here for absolute
quantification we measure measure the
target and RNA copies relative to an
external standard and to sell a per unit
mass but I would like to show that to
you and I hope I can do that in a very
easy way because absolute quantification
determines the absolute copy number of
the sample the CT value of an unknown
sample is here directly compared to a
standard craft of a known standard that
you are using so it's a known are
referencing our standard that you're
using importantly is of course I think
in both quantification methods that the
amplification efficiency of the standard
and the target are equivalent
but what is mostly used when talking to
different scientists is of course
relative quantification using the dalles
of Johnson CT method that is the dollar
compared it's a comparison of the CT
values important here also that those
PCR reactions have the same PCR
efficiency this let us compare the city
of an unknown sample with the city of a
calibrated sample you can see the
different formula so these two different
formulas on the slide when you then
calculate from the CT of the calibrator
with the city of the sample the delta
delta CT value then you put it into the
formula underneath and then you have the
x fold expression level of the genus
interest in comparison to the calibrator
I thought to explain it very easily in
an experiment what you can see here is
we have here an untreated control sample
or example a tissue sample that is non
treated and you can see below the
treated sample we would be interested in
TNF um to check that teen of interest
and we're using as endogenous reference
gene a very popular one which is hprt
that you book a canteen for syrup
acyltransferase what you can see here is
what we're doing here is ideally we do
that in a multiplex experiment but you
can do that also in two experiments that
you have a look at the non-treated
control sample gene of interest t and s
compared to endogenous reference gene
that is the delta CT one then you have a
experiment with the treated sample TNF
hprt and then you have the delta CT two
you put it you subtract it from each
other and then put it in the formula and
then you have the expression level of t
and s your so your gene of interest in
comparison to your endogenous
reference team
you
a few words to entertainers reference
scene before I come to a list of of
endogenous reference genes that could be
used because it's a very important point
and Industry nazar control scene is a
dream whose expression level should not
differ between the samples that is
really very critical so it should not be
up or down regulated in any way the
comparison of the CT values of the
target gene with the endogenous control
gene allows the routine expression level
of the target genes to be normalized to
input erin in your cDNA the endogenous
control gene also use the use of it
corrects for variation in RNA content
reverse transcription efficiency RNA
degradation or inhibition presence in
the RNA sample and differences in the
sample handling so I think it's very
very important I'm always asked how many
endogenous reference seems to use in an
experiment and ideally of course it
should be more than one it should maybe
be up to 3 to start with that you get in
feeling what and the team's reference
cream is for my experiment the best one
um we have on our website also a list of
engines reference genes and we also
indicated the expression level what you
can see on the right side you can see
the different pluses so that you get an
indication how how much they are
expressed because you should have
qualified an endogenous reference gene
which is matching the expression level
of your gene of interest I've also put
up for more information some links into
the presentation there is a very nice
link author from dr. puffer where you
can find a lot of relevant publications
awesome that directions are now coming
to the real time experiment in the
different amplicon detection methods are
we looking to sigh the green and I will
focus on that today that is a sequence
unspecific detection method with of
course fab green as a fluorescent dye
but of course we also have sequence
specific detection methods with
different probes the most important
almost known is to detect meant probes
but also hi probe the interesting probes
molecular beacons MVB probes and
scorpions but as i said today in the
webinar we'll go more into detail into
cyber green real time PCR detector on
the next slide you can see that cyber
green 13 and this dye is excited at 497
nanometers and emits at 529 a meters so
it's double stranded binding dine which
shows increased fluorescence and binding
to the minor groove of the DNA which is
shown then in the picture when binding
to the minor groove of the DNA the
fluorescence signal is increased by
thousandfold
therefore fiber green is one of the most
sensitive detection methods
but it will detect of course all
double-stranded DNA molecules we need to
keep that in mind and therefore will
also detect specific but also
nonspecific PCR products like primer
dimers
therefore the most critical step inside
green analyzes for hives PCR specificity
is the annealing step because only
specific annealing leads to high yield
and highest sensitivity due to high
primer concentration very often we can
also see nonspecific products like
primer dimer or the primer is binding in
a different location or target so you
can see it as a second signal and both
leads to lower yield low sensitivity and
inaccurate in accurate quantification
therefore the mounting curves are shows
and specific products
so the product detected by cyberbrain
can be observed by doing a melt curve at
the end of the reaction that is shown on
this slide in the picture and so the
reaction is heated slowly from 40 to 95
degrees by a cycler whilst continuously
monitoring the fluid send signal the
point at which the double-stranded DNA
mouse is observed as a drop in the fluid
stands as the side of wheel is
dissociating you can see that on the
left side
different bank products and products of
different sequences will melt of course
at different temperatures and be
observed as distinct Peaks when your
cycler is plotting the first negative
derivative of fluorescence versus the
temperature if the PCR reaction is fully
optimized of course it is possible to
produce a multi p profile that contains
only a single peak as you can see on the
blue peak side that represents a
specific product expected from the
primer pair in this situations our
degree in R can be useful for
quantification and also for mutation
detection even amplicons that differ by
a single nucleotide will meld at
slightly different temperatures and can
be distinguished by their melting peaks
what you can also see here is the primer
dimer with PD might peak this is a not a
very sharp peak very much very often
sorry and you can see it is a very broad
peak and it of course primer dimers are
melting at an early temperature and here
it's around 80 degrees this experiment
of course needs to be redone because the
Primus needs to be designed once again
ethnicity a defective influencing the
PCR specificity specificity which is the
amount of starting template primer
design the ions in the erection buffer
and also the tech polymerase the
artifacts done by the tech partners I
would like to focus today on the primer
design and the ions contained in
Direction button
putting primer design um we can give you
also guidance on our website I try to
summarize that because according the
sequence the length of PCR product
should be between 100 and 150 base pair
you should avoid of course complementary
sequences avoids mismatches especially
at the three prime and and avoid at the
three prime and also T's because that
has a greater tolerance of mismatches
award also GC runs at the three prime
end because that will result in stable
mismatched primers length should be
around 18 to 30 nucleotides and GC
content is mentioned also but should not
be above 60% because a high G sequences
will also increase the stability of
primer template but also the primer
primer injection the formula according
the calculation of the TM I have also
listed here and according to
concentration that depends a little bit
on your site should be between 0.3 micro
molar and or point size
you
on the next slide I would like to focus
on the effect of the target length
because that is also important what we
have done here is a one-step real-time
PCR experiment over two hundred ninety
five base pair on a six hundred twenty
six base pair fragments of the better
acting gene that we carried out and the
reactions were performed using varying
amounts of template RNA as indicated
here on the slide the craft crossing
point values are shown for each erection
no crossing point values are given for
amplification of the longer fragment as
you can see with lower minds of template
1 picogram and 10 P program as you can
see
since these reactions produce primer
dimers and nonspecific product in
addition to the specific rt-pcr product
so our recommendation for the optimal
length would be here 100 to 150 base
pair if you work to the buffer
now we jump into a PCR reaction tube
what you can see here is the DNA
backbone of a template another primer
you can see the negative charged a
phosphate group on the left and right
side and then the bases marked with B in
the middle
mm-hmm what is very typical is in
solution the primer and template and due
to a weak hydrogen interaction of the
bases they tend to interact with each
other what is of course in all the PCR
buffers is potassium because it will
stabilize the negative charges of the
phosphate group so that the template and
the primer can interact much better but
we still have here the weak interaction
of hydrogen which leads to nonspecific
interaction what kind in is using very
uniquely is ammonium which is in a deep
protonated in a protonated form you can
see in solution and the deprotonated
form is able to catch the hydrogen ions
and therefore lead to very high
specificity according different ions
magnesium is also interesting because it
will stabilize the annealing process but
only low magnesium concentration leads
to specific annealing the moment gazing
ions he are using the more on specific
product is seen the interesting part is
when using and potassium that leads to
PCR results which are not influenced by
magnesium anymore which makes our lives
much more easier as you can see on the
next slide in where I check the
comparison of these two buffers law in
the left side you can see ammonium
buffer and on the right side a buffer
without ammonium
and we raised the Matthysse in
concentration in both experiments and
you can see in the right side without
ammonium that magnesium has a very
strong effect and you need to play
around what magnesium concentration is
the best because if you used to miss
Emma Hart to high magnesium
concentration that leads to nonspecific
PCR reaction with ammonium you do not
see this effect at all which makes it of
course much easier when using ammonium
in these master mixes for pci qPCR
the same effect of course you can see
then for real-time PCR especially when
we talk about cyber clean where you can
see in the right side the typical prima
donnas signal in the no template control
which is a buffer without ammonium
where the primers and primers tend to
form primer diamond on the left side you
can see the same experiment just with a
volume in the in the buffer system and
there is no signal in the no template
control as you can observe
while police I would like to show you we
are very very proud from our R&D team
what we have developed new from the
hayatun side the new real-time pcr
solutions is called quanta nova and once
again we have I would like to highlight
why we think that we have done here a
good job together high efficient and
sensitive enzyme ready because we have
introduced here a novel antibody made
mediated hot startup mechanism and
that's the new additives that we are
using which is called quanta nova guard
with stabilizing the binding complex
between the DNA polymerize and an
antibody so you can type it this
absolutely safe on room temperature you
can also start at room temperature
because the DNA polymerase remains
inactive in this configuration what we
also have built in you and we will show
that on my next slide is a very new
built-in visual indicator or visual
control so that it's much easier for you
to pipette in the experiment and we have
also accurate results with a rustic
texture of rare targets down to a single
copy and of course you can also use it
for ultra-fast cycling if you have these
kind of cycles in your laboratory
um with my last two slides looking into
these novel additive Quentin over bars
that we have developed new and also
patented that's a novel additive to do
which is stabilizing just a binding
between the poly minds and the antibody
so this arm guard system keeps the
polymerase inactive only if you act you
can activate it in two minutes at 95
degrees because then the antibody and
the gas is dehydrated and the polymerase
is then released and active and I put in
also a video link if you would like to
see that in an animated video version
last not least we have included also
built-in control to minimize pipetting
errors
because these master mix contains an
inert blue dye which when combined with
the yellow template dilution buffer
turns our green so that you are pretty
sure that you have done a correct
reaction setup and of course the inert
dye is not interfering with your PCR
reaction or with your monitoring of the
real-time PCR cycler
if monitoring or B results in
in family of course we have new
continuous fiber green and probe kits
we have also multiplex kids to
streamline the qPCR so we are delivering
here of the highest specificity to two
noble antibody-mediated hop start
mechanism a precise reaction setup with
a built-in visual control that is also
unique and of course no need for
optimization because ammonium is used
and of course you can detect down to a
single copy use it for ultra-fast
sighting and of course in combination
with our quantitate primer essays if
you're interested to get ready to use
and guaranteed primer form
kaijin side
with that one I have also included here
an overview of the continual real-time
PCR kits just a summary on that you can
have a look through that and with that I
would like to thank you for listening to
the webinar and I hope we could help you
developing your new experiment or
developing further your existing
experiments and thank you to everybody
and thanks to a very nice and Judy well
thank you dr. SRAM and dr. Sawyer fluke
for your informative presentations we
will now start the live Q&A portion of
the webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the ask a question drop-down box
located on the far left of your
presentation window type your question
into the box it appears on your screen
and click the send button well answer as
many of your questions as we have time
for so let's get started our first
question is what method should be used
to grow purify both DNA and RNA
yeah so I can take that question that's
a good one actually because it's
becoming more and more important when
people move towards system biology we
have a complete product line for that
which are the all prep products so if
you're looking into DNA and RNA to cope
Yura fication
then these products are the right ones
if it's just about getting total RNA
meaning including micro RNA and ml na as
well as other non-coding RNAs we would
recommend the musi product line thank
you
RNA extraction from facts sorted cells
it is always challenging to extract good
quality and quantity RNA from sorted
cells especially for RNA seek can you
comment on this any collagen products
available
yeah that is a good question and that's
actually true that affects thought
itself are particularly challenging
especially for nvs so we have recently
launched a kid what we call the upx
3-prime transcriptome kids so upx
in this case stands for all collecting
and these kids contain a specific
technology that allow you to go directly
from a couple of cells for example fax
sort itself into the NGS library and it
includes a multiplexing technology or
alpha texting technology which barcodes
every single cell and then also every
molecule within the cell so that's the
solution for the kind of experiment you
were asking about if I deal with cell
culture what is the best way to disrupt
and homogenized the cells
yeah it can also take that so cell
culture is a very common laboratory
sample type so to say and we have really
detailed recommendations in our
handbooks for RNA isolation so you might
want to check the details and the
handbooks to get really the right
guidance for your specific cell culture
however in general what we advise is
that people directly life their cells in
Baja rlt and you can also use Baja rlt
to store your samples and then our
modernized with vortexing that's usually
enough but again look into the handbooks
there might be some more detail advisors
for your specific cell culture do you
have an example for an endogenous
reference gene that could be used for
low expressed genes
I think it can take that one that's a
very very good question
I have shown in my presentation already
hprt but we can of course as I said on
the back side you can find the guidance
for other low expressed gene of interest
because keep in mind better our team is
really high expressed and should not be
used when you have a low expressed gene
of interest so I would recommend hprt
for example because it's very low
expressed here ok thank you we have time
for one more question and it is is the
ammonium buffer system also used in the
client PCR kids
also very good question yes I was
talking today a lot about real-time PCR
and all the other solutions here but of
course we're using that also in our PCR
solutions yes definitely okay well thank
you I would like to once again thank dr.
SRAM and dr. shah rukh for their
presentations i would also like to thank
hydrogen for making today's educational
webcast possible before we go I want to
let everyone know that today's webcast
will be available for on-demand viewing
through August 10th 2018 you'll receive
an email from lab roots letting you know
when this webcast will be available for
replay please share that announcement
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event that is all for now
thank you for joining us we hope to see
you again soon
goodbye